the reason so many of you want to win
right now so fast is you want to show
other people you won this is why credit
cards [__] everyone people want to buy
[__] they can't afford to show people
they're actually winning versus actually
winning we're in a deeply deeply deeply
complicated place where we've always
worried about fronting and impressing
others and that used to be 13 people and
now we live complete public lives and
it's everybody so it's compounded
everybody's taking a hike on the weekend
for the Instagram photo not for the
[__] hike we live in a world where
people yearn for affirmation or
compliments which makes them wildly
vulnerable to booing